is there anyone in the history of the
world who has been worse at their job
than Korean Jean-Pierre like absolutely
worth every single statement she makes
as a representative of this
Administration is a lie or an
obfuscation or a confusion I can't
imagine I cannot imagine someone at any
job ever being worse than what Karin
Jean-Pierre is at her job here she is
yesterday uh saying that January 6 is
the worst attack on Democracy since the
Civil War huh so out for saying you've
heard me say this many times and the
president as well we've been very clear
from the beginning that what we saw on
January 6 was the worst attack on our
democracy since the Civil War and the
president has been very clear our
democracy continues and remains under
threat and we all have a have a part to
protect it it's like nothing should
surprise us anymore right you shouldn't
be surprised by that most vile
disgusting statement
um does she not remember I know she's
she's young but does she not remember uh
you know not too long ago 21 years ago
uh with basically 3 000 I think it's
2996 people American citizens were
killed on 9 11. I lived in New York City
during 9 11 does she not have any
recollection of that the thing is she
does
and that's how they want to escalate
January 6th
right they want you to think it was
worse than 9 11. we put this together I
thought this was kind of clever I was
for saying you've heard me say this many
times and the president as well we've
been very clear from the beginning that
what we saw on January 6 was the worst
attack on our democracy since the Civil
War and the president has been very
clear our democracy continues and
remains under threat and we all have a
have a part to protect it horrible
people horrible people I have no more
jokes to make about her just absolutely
horrible people and and not deserving of
standing at that Podium and to me and I
know it's like it's by Design so they
will never and they can't fire her right
because then if if they were to fire her
she would say that the Biden
Administration is anti-black and
anti-lesbian even though we just brought
that lesbian back from Russia but that's
what she would do because diversity
these diversity hires basically put you
in a hostage situation but that is
inexcusable and embarrassing and it's
just so consistent with everything that
these people do